but you got Star Wars news we have
playstation news and we have Xbox news
I'm Kurt Davina and this is safe state
for Monday June 15th welcome you made it
EA has officially announced star wars
squadrons an immersive first-person
space dogfighting experience the
creative director of motive studios in
Frasier said quote we created this game
for every Star Wars fan who has ever
dreamt about soaring across the galaxy
in their favorite star fighter so it's
gonna be an original story but whether
or not it's Canon we don't know yet it
will have new original characters and
also cameos from existing ones like
wedge antilles in her Ross and doula and
of course it's got a multiplayer the
game will feature a few modes including
a strategic squad based battle mode a
dogfight mode and more also yes it's got
cosmetics but before you jump to any
conclusions EA was very clear to state
that this game has no microtransactions
so good on you EA for being upfront
about it well sadly we haven't seen any
gameplay for it but we won't have to
wait for long because EA will be showing
off during eat a play on June 18th which
is that's Thursday so that's sweet you
may not know this but the PS 5 was
revealed last week it happened it's a
thing it exists however we have
absolutely no idea what it'll cost still
and I think they're trying to figure
that out
still PlayStation boss a Jim Ryan told
BBC that they're working on the right
value equation for it saying
conventional wisdom and history show
that our business is one of the more
recession-proof businesses but I think
this will sharpen our need to ensure
that we focus on getting the value
equation right and I emphasize value
opposed to price he also didn't specify
whether there will be a difference for
the standard and digital edition former
Xbox marketing head Albert penelo
predicted on Twitter that the PS 5 won't
be more than five hundred dollars at
this point we have no idea what either
the Xbox Series X or the PS 5 will cost
and of course we all have a ton of
speculation in fact we did a prediction
article on what it might cost and you
can find a link to that in the
description below
at this point my prediction is that it
says it's gonna cost money that's all I
know
that's all I got it's not
constructive I know but observe that at
least speaking of next-gen Xbox have
been talking a bunch about smart
delivery which is where if you buy a
game on Xbox one you get it
automatically on the Xbox Series X smart
delivery is going to be for all first
party games and third-party devs will
make their own decision whether or not
they want to do it but you know it'd be
like sweet if they did do it just saying
I'd be like sweet smart delivery will
also apply to game pass and your save
data will be transferable some games
confirmed are Assassin's Creed Valhalla
cyberpunk 2077 Yakuza like a dragon and
Halo infinite there's also a bunch
others you can see the full list by
following the link to the new story in
the description below also while you're
here it's a good time to remind you
about plate for all GameSpot's multi
week sweet cool fun video game event
where we're also raising money for black
lives matter and people fighting on the
front line for coab in nineteen relief
every single day from 12:00 p.m. Pt to
2:00 p.m. Pt we're having sweet streams
with sweet special guests and it's all
to raise money for charity alongside
that we're having a bunch of exclusive
content like interviews and previews and
all that fun stuff that you would
otherwise be getting at e3 but III is
didn't happen but that's okay we got you
covered
we got cool stuff that we're doing and
that we're sharing so be on the lookout
for that and that's all the exciting
news that we have for today of course
there's that and a whole bunch more at
gamespot.com so be sure to go there and
check it out and stay informed and be
able today and all the cool video game
stuff that's happening I'm Curtin Divina
thanks for joining me be well until next
time see you later
[Music]